don't look at me that way Bob I didn't I
didn't want this happen oh and he's dead
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the eye surgery in
corridor mode and this is gonna be
horrifying I know I know I know I know
nurse doctor just shut up nurse until
you remember your identity you shall
remain silent and I need this not that
acts as much as I want that axe and
today ass I don't know about you nurse
so shut the F up cut cut cut
boys it's not cutting twice it's not
cutting it should be cutting he's gonna
die already cuz I can't oh come on stop
hiding it with your fat head Bob come on
get the angle cut uh huh
I got that goggles off yeah okay what do
you got for me what again this this I'll
take it Oh get back here you'll go in
the eyeball and then you're gonna scoop
around of it you're feeling good Bob
you're feeling good oh okay Oh poopy
school Oh God
what doctor shouldn't I be in the
operation room shut up Bob I obviously
know better than you how the hell do I
get that out of there again didn't I use
this thing I use this thing oddly enough
this is best I think
boo boo Boop oh oh it's too good it's
too good
your heart rates a little high have some
liquid crack cocaine or something like
that now I need not you not you God give
me something to cut with please please
anything to cut with okay nothin nothing
apparently stop your heart rate descent
all right come on give me something to
cut with there's nothing in there oh
well I don't I don't I don't know if
that's bad come on come on come on some
to cut with some to cut with that'll do
I think no not that not that that that
that stop looking at me like that Bob
what's over there there's something
better to come with new no there's no no
no
so let's look for something else oh I
need that I need these give me one of
these and give me one of these I want to
hold these over here for safekeeping
no don't you run out on me no don't you
call me where are you and you stay right
there good like a good little I bought
new Oh what am i doing what am I done
done horrible things even you're looking
at me old judgmental like I'll be doing
it doing something that God worth
goddamn least I can stop the bleeding
okay finally an actual precision cutting
is driven sweating up a storm get that
out of the eyeball this is a hammer
oh well alright alright alright go today
Bob they'll be eyeballing that turn your
head Bob turn away you don't wanna see
this ready then it back
dananana double organ ma turn your head
let me got it there we go good boy
yeah don't school me I need this hey
turn that off I'll put this in your
eyeball what's over there some I can use
I also only those yeah school bully over
the school they're good that's good
put this in your other eyeball no put it
what's over there nothing nothing you
for school I'll need a little scalpels
later I probably couldn't use the spoon
I didn't even think about this boom I
don't you join me bud it was a close one
babe your clothes will get in there ha
ha all right you come here you oddly
good instrument at getting the eye balls
out of the face oh but I'm over him over
you
why is it still the I shun me boop boop
boop boop boop there we go
looking good Bob walking good there we
go
I can't take my time on this one oh come
on I need a better cutter Oh the
scissors baby come on but I wasn't
watching my blood I shouldn't be a
doctor I didn't even really get my
diploma for bigger red Oh why's it gotta
be so hard
oh come on go to the other side of the
vase just rest on those glasses
get over here I need to see what's on
that cart got you [ __ ] hi there God god
dammit the south I wanted oh okay fine
fine fine fine fine
get in there get in there what's over
here oh no he's different providing who
was there something good on that cart
that I saw I don't know maybe push the
button give me no nothing get the
eyeballs out one down I think a scalpel
was meant for this no he's gonna die Oh
get out of the eye okay
he's gonna die and Nicky's back oh
you're gonna die from an injury to the
eye Oh green please go me please
no God acts please help Oh goddamn it
okay
they finally cut through you okay what
do I got anti blood but he's not
bleeding too blue oh no Claire bull get
that
yes like that I'm gonna take this with
me
god damnit not that no dad there goes my
spoon here oh god why did I leave that
on no it's not charged ball doctor are
those the Blackbird okay it work thank
you man come on please cooperate with me
Bob there we go whoo whoo all right one
do and where did it go where did it go
oh it's not gonna give me another
eyeball
forever you ass can I see it I know it's
under there somewhere
oh no I bought what I'll beg top prize
for baked goods it's gonna be like whoa
whoa boy there we go
we get another actual I we drop this in
four so have I almost I was very close
to getting perfect numbers two thousand
milliliters three minutes could have
been perfect but it's just slightly not
perfect which is the story of my life so
anyway oh I cannot imagine doing the tea
surgery guys don't make me do it don't
beg we do it please don't bake we do it
I don't want to do it ignore the smile
on my face I don't want to do it yeah so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for videos
that I've done you appreciate the work
that I go through for you guys right you
appreciate you appreciate this little
shine of sweat thanks again everyone for
watching and as always I will see you